me enseñó no creer a todas las historias
que creí discúlpenme por no creer mucho
de lo que escuché hoy por parte del
presidente biden desde la inflación
fuera de control la crisis
y las amenazas de China biden y los
demócratas han fracasado les han fallado
ellos lo saben Y ustedes lo saben y es
momento de un cambio hoy
reafirmemos nuestro compromiso con una
idea temporal estadounidense que el
gobierno existe no para darle órdenes al
pueblo sino para servirle al pueblo los
demócratas quieren gobernarnos con más
Control pero eso no es lo que somos
Estados Unidos es el país más grande que
el mundo ha conocido porque somos el
país más libre que el mundo ha conocido
con la gente que es fuerte con un pueblo
resiliente hace cinco meses se me
diagnóstico con cáncer de la si fue un
momento difícil para nuestra familia
particularmente para nuestros niños
Scarlett y George pero mantuvimos
nuestra fe y perseveramos gracias a los
doctores excepcionales que están aquí en
Arkansas son una cirugía exitosa y la
gracia de Dios
soy libre de cáncer
y Durante este proceso no podía dejar de
pensar en mi madre
tenía 20 años y en su primer año de
matrimonio fue diagnosticada con cáncer
en la espina
los doctores le dijeron que ya no podría
no vivir y si ella vivía eligieron que
no podría caminar de nuevo y si caminaba
definitivamente no podría volver a tener
hijos
la hija que se le dijo que no podría
tener acaba de ser juramentada como
gobernadora de Arkansas y está
hablándoles a ustedes hoy
la adversidad y el miedo de lo
desconocido puede ser paralizante pero
la fe nos motiva a enfrentar esa
situación
con osadía y no podemos quedarnos
quietos ante grandes desafíos usted y yo
estamos en esta tierra por momentos como
estos por enfrentar con osadía las
dificultades soy la primera en aceptar
que el presidente vaiden y yo no tenemos
mucho en común yo busco la libertad él
Busca el control gubernamental a los 40
años soy la gobernadora más joven del
país a los 80 él es el presidente más
viejo en la historia estadounidense yo
soy la primera mujer en liderar este
estado y él es el primer hombre en
rendir su presidencia a una multitud
progresista que ni siquiera puede decir
que es una mujer en la izquierda radical
estadounidense Washington aumenta los
impuestos y acaba con tu dinero pero
a imaginarnos con Los Altos precios de
la gasolina sin los víveres con
enseñanzas de que los niños deben
odiarse el uno al otro basados en La
Raza no amarse no amar a su gran país
sea que Joe biden crea que esta locura
está bien o sea que es suficientemente
débil para resistirla su administración
ha sido completamente tomada por la
izquierda radical
la línea división Estados Unidos no es
entre la derecha y la izquierda la
elección es entre la normalidad y la
locura es momento de que una nueva
generación de líderes republicanos
aparezca
tras tomar el cargo hace unos cuantos
semanas firmé una orden firmé varias
órdenes para
acabar con el cereté con la
adoctrinamiento de nuestras escuelas
repelimos las órdenes de covid dijimos
que no íbamos a asumir estos mandatos
autoritarios
los estadounidenses quieren sentido
común por parte de sus líderes pero en
Washington la administración de biden
está duplicando
su dosis de locura el presidente biden
eneró heredó la mayor recuperación
económica en el registro histórico la
frontera más segura la energía abundante
y local unos salarios en aumento un
ejército reconstruido un mundo estable
en paz pero los últimos dos años los
demócratas destruyeron todo a pesar de
el gasto irresponsable las montañas de
deudas traía a los poros demócratas
tenemos la peor crisis migratoria y
fronteriza en la historia del país como
madre tengo el corazón roto por los
padres que han perdido y José hijas a la
adicción cientos de miles de
estadounidenses al año están muriendo
por sobredosis mayormente por el
fentanilo que atraviesa nuestras
fronteras sin embargo la administración
se niega asegurar nuestra frontera y a
salvar las vidas estadounidenses
tras años de carga
demócrata sobre las fuerzas policiales
quitarle patrocinio a la policía
mientras las familias viven en miedo
bueno Más allá de la frontera Afganistán
de Ucrania de Corea del Norte eran el
presidente biden su debilidad pone a
nuestra nación y pone al mundo en riesgo
la negativa del presidente de defenderse
ante china que nuestro adversario más
formidable es peligrosa y es inaceptable
presidente no está dispuesto a defender
nuestra frontera no está dispuesto a
defender nuestros cielos no está
dispuesto a defender a nuestro pueblo
simplemente es incapaz
de servir como comandante jefe
y mientras se cosechan las consecuencias
de sus fracasos la administración biden
sigue más interesada en fantasías
progresistas más interesada en esto que
la realidad es estadounidenses la
mayoría estadounidense simplemente
quiere vivir su vida en paz en libertad
pero estamos bajo ataque en una guerra
cultural por parte de la izquierda que
nunca pensamos y no quisimos empezar
cada día se nos dice que tenemos que
adorar sus ídolos falsos mientras el
gobierno entra en colusión con las
grandes empresas tecnológicas y le
quitan la libertad de discurso a los
estadounidenses es una de las libertades
que más importan pero eso es normal Eso
es equivocado eso es error aquí no
podemos cometer errores los republicanos
no van a Rendirse en esta pelea vamos a
liderar con coraje Vamos a hacer todo lo
correcto no lo que es políticamente
correcto o conveniente los republicanos
creen en un Estados Unidos
donde las familias fuertes logran El
Progreso donde Hay comunidades seguras
donde los trabajos son abundantes donde
los cheques están creciendo
donde pretendemos la libertad de
nuestros veteranos donde la libertad es
el derecho de nacimiento de cada mujer
niño hombre
son las libertades por las que los
republicanos estamos luchando en
Washington bajo liderazgo de los
senadores republicanos y del líder Kevin
macarthy y nosotros sostendremos haremos
que la administración de biden sea
responsable
justo al final de la calle donde vivo
está Mi Alma Mater Little Rock Central
High la escuela de Little Rock como
estudiante allá nunca olvidaré ver a mi
padre al gobernador Mike y el presidente
Bill Clinton
abrir las puertas para los niños de
Little Rock puertas que 40 años antes
habían estado cerradas a niños negros y
hoy esos niños
bueno que alguna vez se enfrentaron la
entrada Ahora son héroes que están
inmortalizados a las puertas de nuestra
escuela me enorgullece El Progreso que
ha tenido nuestro país y creo que cada
niño debe tener acceso
a una educación de calidad sin importar
la raza o el ingreso es el tema Este es
el tema de los Derechos civiles de
nuestra época mañana develaré un paquete
educativo que
será la reforma conservadora educativa
más importante la historia del país mi
plan en poder a los padres con
elecciones reales mejora la
alfabetización la lectura y ayuda a
ubicar a un buen profesor en cada salón
de clase incrementando sus salarios de
entrada pasando de uno de los más bajos
a uno de los más altos en la nación aquí
en Arkansas y en todo Estados Unidos los
republicanos están trabajando para
acabar con esta política de atrapar a
los niños en escuelas fracasadas y
sentenciarlos a una vida de pobreza
nosotros vamos a educar no vamos a
adoctrinar vamos a poner a los niños en
un camino al éxito a los estudiantes en
un camino al éxito
es momento de que una nueva generación
líder el camino este es nuestro momento
Esta es nuestra oportunidad una nueva
generación nacida en las últimas décadas
del último siglo sacudida por
situaciones del mercado bursátil de la
economía forjados por el triunfo de la
guerra fría y la tragedia del 9/11 una
generación
llena de pasión y de ideas nuevas para
resolver problemas de décadas una
generación apegada a las más viejas
tradiciones a los mejores valores pero
que no teme de desafiar al presidente y
encontrar lo mejor camino
si asumimos este momento juntos Estados
Unidos puede ser de nuevo la ley la
tierra de los Libres el hogar de los
valientes
durante mis dos años y medio en la casa
blanca
Viajé hice estuve en cada viaje
extranjero con el presidente un viaje
que jamás olvidaré fue el 25 de
diciembre 2018
mi esposo Brian y yo acabábamos de
acabar de limpiar bueno en papel de
regalo que estuvo en nuestras casas
estaba en cada Rincón de nuestra casa
cuando tuve que salir de la Navidad de
mi propia familia incapaz de decirles a
dónde iba esa noche porque el lugar al
que iba era tan peligroso
que no quería que nadie supiera que el
presidente iba a estar allá en
territorio incluso por unas cuantas
horas
abordamos el Air Force One en mayor
oscuridad de la noche no había luces en
el avión no había luces en la pista de
aterrizaje nuestros teléfonos y
computadores estaban apagados
nos alejamos completamente nos
desconectamos completamente doce horas
después
en la oscuridad de la noche
aterrizamos en una parte bueno atacada
por la guerra del occidente de iraquí
fue una situación similar no había luces
en el avión
no haya luces en la pista
lo único que se podía ver venía de una
milla a distancia
una
casino de alimentación
donde habían cientos de soldados
luchando para celebrar la Navidad con el
liderazgo militar de la región
y no tenía la más mínima idea de que el
presidente y la primera dama iban a
llegar a esa habitación cuando ellos
llegaron
fue
una escena fue un sonido que espero
jamás olvidar
la habitación explotó
jóvenes hombres mujeres de cada edad
religión cada partido político cada
grupo demográfico que usted pueda
imaginar empezó a cantar en unísono
perfecto una y otra vez
USA
fue una imagen Perfecta de lo que hace
que nuestro país sea increíble uno de
los jóvenes soldados gritó desde la
parte de atrás señor presidente
me reenliste por usted
el presidente dijo hijo estoy aquí por
usted
Poco después ese joven soldado me se
acercó a mí y dijo ser
tienes un trabajo difícil yo le dije lo
que hago no es nada
recibes bombas recibes balas amenazas
eso es un trabajo difícil en un momento
que sé que apreciaré por el resto de mi
vida ese soldado se acercó y me regaló
el parche que tenía en su hombro me puse
mi mano
una señal del mayor respeto posible él
dijo ser
estamos en esto juntos
avasallada por la emoción sin ningún
tipo de palabra posible solamente lo
abracé tenía lágrimas en los ojos y un
corazón agradecido pensando Los Héroes
que nos mantienen libres ese joven cada
joven que ha servido antes que él todo
ellos todos los que sirven al lado del
hombre los miles que sabemos que serán
llamados a servir después de él merecen
saber que tienen un país y una comunidad
que hace su parte en la lucha en nombre
de la Libertad
Estados Unidos es grande porque somos
libres pero hoy nuestra libertad está
bajo ataque
en Estados Unidos que ama que amamos
está en peligro el presidente biden y
los demócratas les han fracasado
es momento de un cambio
una nueva generación de líderes
republicanos está dando el paso hacia
adelante no para cuidar el statu quo
sino para lograr el cambio en nombre del
pueblo estadounidense
no sabemos que tiene el futuro en sus
manos Pero sabemos quién tiene al futuro
en sus manos
con Dios como testigo
le mostraremos al mundo que Estados
Unidos sigue siendo el lugar donde la
libertad reina y la libertad jamás
morirá Muchas gracias Dios los bendiga y
Dios bendiga a Estados Unidos